foreign
thank you
good morning everyone
so it's been two
um the inquiry relations
um standard 36 countries in I haven't
gotten things that I mean toys this
morning
um
so I'm expecting a new rolling this
morning
um so would you like to come
[Music]
good morning um thank you for allowing
the opportunity to continue the
progression for a short time as well hi
my name is
before I make my formal remarks on the
bill itself I just think it's not the
terminology
and secondly I reckon that I recognize
that as a member of parliament who had
no formal role in the primary sexual
disabilities on a personal basis
I do not request to speak of being in
the field on a regular basis outside of
the local fund instructions which is
only an experience
for six years I've got the record voting
established yet this is one which is of
such reality for the community for much
that uh I wanted to speak
in 2017. I recognized planning to have
to have a difficult job on a great
respect for the work that they do not
release foreign
and the disability not to see this
application is inappropriate um
residence ability outline their concerns
in detail and they will not seeking
people play those points other than sort
of rules instead are you just like to
highlight three specific matters which I
hope you expect to be taking for
accounting for consideration firstly
this application is accepted by all
parties to be a further inversion into
the greenhouse over a number of people
already that he's learned
but where this application seems to take
further land including so many of them
beyond that that allowance will be
changed specifically for the reason of
accommodating as widely development
these problems will be built which will
be visible within the aspective nor is
the overall area within which the police
will be situated according to the
profoundly small which shows them to be
around 10 of the inside of sun this is a
vital part of the development which will
change the natural run around it
including our languages
the invisible to the community for the
potentially significantly there's
significantly distancing way and which
seems to develop around the national
funding policies
Department says the normal circumstances
should be developed from the policy
access time in the local bank would not
be clearer that can impressive
development will not be able to drop
that in very special circumstances there
is no reference in part three of that
policy that states that mitigations for
adjacent energy
no very special circumstances exists and
based on a principle and a visual basis
secondly
this application is for 20 more than any
other providers in the local bank
something which the average person would
not consider to be in the approximate
value
so then secretary into Greenville line
on the basis that the other area or the
Middle East should be used to construct
significantly more properties than the
local planets and Jazz he's not
sustainable
boom finally the inclusion into the
green bowel also highlights the further
use of land which is being associated
with potential historical Line work
things and with that being said because
look again and the questions regarding
is our use of this site there is genuine
and significant concern with anything
that has full understanding of the
challenges on itself due to its historic
Nature has not been adequately or
comprehensively considered 60 meters
both the appropriateness of construction
on the site and then the potential
long-term potential substance at least
one form of minor who is employed at the
site has come forward is Right extracts
concern that the site has significant
greater challenges around historic mine
workings and language and fundamentation
to take even more loans which may have
been associated with one working that's
only exacerbates the potential
challenging from this matter
there are many reasons why this appeal
to the rejected but I will not be
telling you into that they've been
articulating separately including
funny ones wherever this has been
interesting long wearing a difficulture
with the residence
and I hope you can see the same feeling
from them and sustainability
the constituency celebration is always
recognized that more Heritage
and across the entire area significant
additional development is coming we will
play our problems where residents have
significant and buried concerns when the
developers seek to utilize sites in a
way that you're not sustainable and not
appropriately this is in my view the
position that we're still within
consequently when we expect the goals of
inclusion in the coming months ahead I
hope it should be taken to A banks the
encouraging interview developers are
necessary and this application requires
that land with potential mining issues
only require in order to build a greater
number of properties
should be dismissed on that ground alone
thank you
thank you in history
um
um in line with national policy
commenting that they were engineering
operations
Beyond scientists such problems in
princes for our engineering operations
not necessarily I believe everything
should be looked at and it's a merit
from the whole principles
circumstances
a very special certain extensive means
what it is
in terms of motivations of an
application if you're ready to uh should
not be considered very specially
circumstances
Channel
[Music]
I'm not the only comments for discussion
elsewhere and that assignment decisions
to stay with this development requires
impressions of email which should not be
protected
information not a visibility doesn't
have this agriculture or having their
own self it's deep are you familiar with
paragraph one things
that I know is embarrassed that you will
also be familiar with the principles
and a local policy shipping services
at the beginning of my response to these
questions is that no no special effects
that exists in this Regard in this
specific application and networking
female privately decisions
too so you're saying yeah
um
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
fully
I've just about seeing I think my
signpost is that we were going to a very
spoken about the background to the
allocation in the local time and it's
what you said it 6.2 of your proof we
say the size of the shape of the
allocation these are promoting and
explaining about your position on that
yesterday and then at 6.3 you would
developed to the
um submission that had been booked by
Coda to the local code remember yes and
you referred us in particular to the
core document I don't think we need to
turn it up but it was four one one C at
the end of which was a little uh
master plan I want to go back to our
instruction
now that submission I understand was not
to the examination but to the regulation
19 study of the plan it was February
2018 and I think he said so in law
enroll statement I guess
so what I'd like to just look at next is
the timeline of chronology because the
application which is the subject of
disappeared was made and it's in actual
record October 2018.
and we'll see that from the application
performance means taken over season one
two one
um now that application
always heard from the moment it was
launched in October 2018
um the ascent basins in the graveyard
because we need to have a look at that
and we see the very first master plan
which is in the core documents
it's the core document 116.
foreign
[Music]
and the application going in there's
obviously been a change of
the programs in relation to service
and the location and relations
and then if you have a look at um
documents four one one
who see the hearing statement which was
put to the political time examining
inspector
[Music]
we will see that what is being done is
responding to questions Finance Factor
main masses putting Evolution all over
the planet two three one
[Music]
name maxo 240 Main matter whether or not
the proposed houses and allocation to
sell for those the deliverable
[Music]
this is the case as expressed in the
statement of the common ground with
mechanics and detailed in the electline
planning accessibility that means clear
the application and gives the reference
and that's this
from an appeal application isn't it
do you want to just check that that
reference Town isn't the reference to
this application this application
is 180100
there wasn't another application that
was submitted an outline at that time
was it
okay
and so by response to the instructor's
question the inspector is taken to the
outline application the plan for which
is the one we've just seen at that point
in time
then in response to question B what's
the likely impact of the closed
development following factors we'll see
that the last of those factors is flood
risks
and the response from code there are no
lighting material detrimental harmful
impacts with those development
generations to these factors the
evidence and support of the outlined by
the implementation very very clearly
demonstrates this fact
apparently speaking as soon as a game
for this same application this
application
which found social problems the basis
in documents
and then if we have a look into the
local time inspectors report
which is just a little bit further on in
the same set of chord arguments four one
two
thank you
we've got the loads of fun inspectors
we see that the hearing sessions took
place between November
2018 and March 2019 on the front page
and then if we go to look at
[Music]
um
this side
report
what she says is based on the technical
assessments submitted with the outline
application for residential development
that orange has gone 393 women's
more cautious to researching she is
referring to and there was only one
there is only has only been one out by
application for development to the side
she is referring both to it and the
technical assessments the support of
Education
it's all basins in the green one
that was never my understanding nobody
must be now looking what the actual
papers
High continents like this
is
well that I've understood is that the
silver analysis
have to say right
maybe this is
both the technical assessments really to
the technical assessments currently
being a line application was fully aware
of it
right except that you're showing me
these documents now
they're publicly
documents it's not it's not been my
understanding but Focus all the help
what's up
there's a reference to this specific
application instead is talking about
other than being illuminately based on
this site there's not been married
so
your your narrative there is that um I
was
in the gist of the order point it says
but I would sort of source
of those things
um but the reality show me is this
foreign
and
nobody suggested there was a route to
advise that we development
and surely not simply because in line
with the ultimate position of policy and
the case officers and lying with other
Appeals
it was absolutely fine and to be
expected to be quite normal and her
son's faces or at least not to put in
this instance and you bring them nobody
would bat an island to think that
there's a reason to change their own
attention because it is quite astounding
isn't it always seem unto them
to answer
that there's a reason why the Apparently
was put in that bar and I've made that
feeling my statement to explain why I
went yesterday
and we've got an allocation of pr1 but
we appreciate this isn't an exercise in
trying to rewards information
is
really Keen to understand where you're
going uh because it makes a difference
to a whole series of questions
you've seen in your freeze at 6.5
there's any harm to bring them out is to
be given substantial weight in the refer
to the right forward
and
then you say at age 20
at the end of your analysis when you
have come to the view that it is
that therefore it's necessary to go on
to constantly the degree of time
and I just want to understand this
it's I think I think you're saying
that you only consider the degree of
time
and the question of substantial weight
to it
if you have completed the developments
and that's what you have done and it's
not the right approach is that the
approach you are applying and suggesting
to be aesthetical
up on
and then whether it's outweighed by
essential protections Phoenix plus
that's that was my thought process
because
let me just sort of book appointment
number one because maybe I haven't
certain names
if we expect a disagrees with you and
agrees with Mr Rollins those applying uh
this is just
foreign
my composition is this if it is
concluded then the proposals preserve
openness we don't conflict with
practices then it is
development and that's the end of the
assessment
I can't agree to that
um
[Music]
so I need to say it's there
these data
obviously in the nvpn and we haven't got
the material changes in our last set of
points in the service volume
but it does say that they're not in a
group yeah provided they deserve itself
so I will look at all that together
I know you're trying to uh I'm just
trying to establish what needed by the
right text
sorry maybe on the basis settings
and we see all the causes of appears so
it's very clear that we apply the
exceptions whether it's 150 or is it
building as it's 149
you make that judgment you do not then
go back to what it's always and get very
substantial weight to any harm whatever
it might be
and I'm trying to establish whether that
is what you have done of course against
things
it's a matter for legal submissions
perhaps but to do so will be an error of
law is that not even done
so do you even
take that point that once you've applied
150 a few conclude that this is approved
built applying those systems
that is
there is no rewards consider in terms of
the human environment with regard to one
thing
with regards to like to save that point
about this is that
um they're not also not in a group of
provided yeah
my point being you do not then go back
and ask yourself about substantial
weights
so that's for that balancing various
metal circumstances
[Music]
foreign so can I ask you this is it your
approach in your cruise and was it the
approach of the council having brought
to the end of one
regardless of the answer
you still have to do two and three
no I'm asking what your approaches
but of course I immediately at some
point too already
if the answer to one is that it is not
inappropriate but do you have to apply
it to
foreign
[Music]
the term preserve openness he said means
having an infant effect on openness High
openness of the green that would not at
all to be not at all to be negatively
impacted even to the smallest degree
yeah
what do you take that from
who's totally that's so advice about my
location
it's not the advice that they put
forward in their uh Assessments in the
office of the report so when was it
um
did you did you apply that test
yes yes so if that test isn't right
what questions you want to judgments in
your approach to the whole thing
well I'll put your questions so
just one principle if that's not the
right approach
then it's highly likely you'll have got
the wrong answer by applying
foreign
in writing
um
so
when when we have a case more like
um the Supreme Court and Samuel
schnitzel Brothers which is in cd61
energy
you know
I think wants to eat cleaning
personal there was even to the smallest
degree I think that comes from a
wonderful arrays
to see so so what you have done it seems
is applying 148
as part of the judgment about openings
answered the judgment about compliance
with 150 in preservation but equipment
that succeeds and what you've just told
them that you'll find 148
industrial approach
there's parts of it there but that's
that's talking about any parts that
you're involved
I really talk about negative effects
that you involve negative effectively
openness now negative effects to the
organized
how about you there and my understanding
is that that is
that so I think I've gotten your answer
to the previous appointment if you are
applying the substantial weights or any
harm to greetings out when you consider
preservation about
even reported 148 into the judgments he
wanted
I'd consider that has been less fun
Parts projects and here together
right now let's actually have a look at
what the court was saying paragraph 22
of the Senate semester case
of course is very clear about describing
openness nor does it in one freedom from
any form of development this staging
level if we're doing in paragraph 22.
so the Supreme Court is quite clear that
openness does not imply freedom from any
form of development
and that is clear because you have
exceptions to Green around in one four
nine and one safety where there are
several things that can be acceptable
completely engineering operations
so development
is acceptable
in the greenhouse
it's not an indication of freedom
like that
and
this on your approach then would have to
be development that doesn't have any
effect whatsoever
not even to the smallest degree
of upsetting 8.8 I understand by what it
says
there is something a mutual effects of
the openness of green belt is not all
negatively imperative even to the
smallest evidence
certainly was this and
mineral operations
mineral extraction
and the instances that we had before us
in the paperwork
so some students okay summer science
there's an extension six languages two
million tons of rocks
do you think with that would not have
any effect on openness not even to the
smallest degree yeah
and it was
a new Supreme Court was
foreign
whatsoever
and are you really saying that all of
those instances were genuinely something
which did not have any effect on the
openness of the green note nothing into
the smallest
I can't speak about those because uh
they're not ones I've looked on
um I've got a monthly commented on this
one here can you imagine any situation
where mineral extraction or engineering
or operation is a local transport
infrastructure or even if we go to
France
the buildings brought forward into the
community rights to build
can you imagine any instances they
wouldn't have no effect at all and the
openness of the room
can you imagine any situation where that
could be possible
what I've done is uh and give you my
evidence
of giving it on
this appeared on the hill am I but I
haven't done this individual basis I
find that quite difficult to give a
review on here so many have seen for the
first time and that's because well not
doing things
[Music]
tell me about it
all right let's have a look at your
approach to home unless here so that's
that's sort of the approach for this is
the application
um 8.3
and you say invest the words that
involves
um tanks real soils piping head walls
you know 8.6 you go on to talk about
buildings
a lot of those are shown in the brick
about something else
and as we as we agreed yesterday we make
a little condition and to make sure
that's the campaign
um
and we were clear that sort of creation
of some spaces is an engineering
operations
um
so when you come to 8.9
and what you're saying here and it said
I think it kind of relates to your
comments about the long section what we
looked at yesterday we're saying that no
indication of material being removed
from the Sun
so it must be excavated and reused when
there's a surprise sequence it must
increase volume
yeah
um
the first point is
it's actually an assumption of something
that you've made against have you not
done any calculations based on those
plans about the incentives
uh my comments are related to the
information that was available which is
that what the two universities
present it of the extensive customer
service associated with operating ways
we knew we are there
and although we're talking substantial
based on uh based on a lot of juvenile
station we can't be a little between
half a kilometers across a lot of those
sort of and adding to them in their area
please but what you can see in the
middle
is that the science is just the
substance so if there's one's removed
so
so not only do you have no assassin
should be actually the doctoral balance
in the service area but no accessibility
we actually don't throw those across
Society including this so I've been
unable now
and if material is indeed
just as soon for a moment that within
the sun's area there was a begin sort of
Council of settlement so what was that
was used to think
then in fact there would be no English
supporting because there were no
importation of material at all it would
just be moving it away
well we don't know about it we don't
know we also gets Steven that you didn't
and in anything there's an addition of
water as well yesterday but we do know
this and that values with water so we
regular basis it's the basis of learning
below what's complaining about product
have you have you explored or examined
the extensions
um
the notes I have on this
meeting courses
two or three times a year mostly to the
depth of about 100 million
um
one liter depth two or three times in
the life of the development
very Transit trainers
it'll be better
and do you have any any challenge
so when you said
uh in age 10 that there could be points
and Chambers and they might involve
digging out the chair and replacing them
around the water are there any parts or
changes
so any underground scientific parts of
control Chambers
they've installed like it's only
recently we've said that uh equals there
[Music]
so this is um
there I say sort of scare mongering if
something really bad happened it would
be really bad that's a suggested the
point of making a relationships
and you're not suggesting vegetative
um
in relationship between the
um the long section that you were
assigned to guide yesterday remember
instance
it's it's in Mr Robinson's appendices
that's where I'm looking too and it's
three second time
well overnight we've had a look at your
your five meeting point
um
[Music]
just just some factual points so
allowance
that rises to the south of the
Green Valley is a man-made structure
that sounds a bit of symbolio insect
that's been greened over
here
so the value itself is created by a
coming week it's been placed there as a
consequence of mind
I said
images
so the five weeks this point you'll see
as we on the on the top line the long
section
is the second then from the left
not foreign
[Music]
it's over 21 meters it's a 14 degree
angle it's the one in four I can't I
can't see that we're looking guys I
don't think we read those down tonight
but there's the top one it looks like
two and a half
yeah that's the next one three or five
and then four four
minutes so when you were just fine he's
just trying to put contacts around the
language you were using and you were
saying it was a fine means of damn world
yesterday
foreign
would have the conceptions
and this enables us to see how in
cross-section
the Steep falling land of the tip to the
South
and the falling land of the site itself
to the north
which is actually on the cross-section
to the
first to the right to move to the left
is tied in
so whether those
higher points are
is section d
and section g
so to get to get to the populated
context
indeed receipt here how that turns in
to the landform North and South
and June now at times
foreign
telling me to both
because I look at both these pictures
I'd rather you I've got a new process
that it is an opportunity
[Music]
right what's the gradient of the team
of Department
as well
I'm sure
for telling languages to come but that's
about 1.1 in six one in seven
and the Steve is still talking about
here is about warning form
s ago
okay
but you're saying this is wholly
announced a bit more than one
not using
right
your photographs so I'm sort of moving
on to a
[Music]
thank you
we all produce your service European
lead Squad
your photograph form at the end of this
one
being pointing out the line of the
things
what I would need is a lot of things
that need my uh I can tell us something
for example on five with the seats in
the bottom yeah let's take a look at the
same
to consume that and consumers
if I can get my uh my diary
just one second
yeah
there's a lot of the side with the
direction
so we see that photograph one has taken
pointing right around the mountbound one
so that's why today okay
thank you
um
guarantee
this is
so just just to run clear
it's funny
on the left side of the photograph but
then again then the little one and the
posting Rail and the next supervisors of
the bookshops
and that's the only of that particular
section it is much more important
I was the green melt boundary man
what you've got to consider at the time
of the year as well those those butchers
aren't this thing
so all the sounds
much bigger
much heavier
and the gist of your case seems to be
that if the pond facing was considered
the right hand side about those two
whale offense or even tournament landing
at the fence
the the
five leads a difference there
with the water sat part way up the hill
into the side this is unclear that in
visual terms you say that's acceptable
but utilizing the the natural upslope of
the team
and not doing too much to create a
bottom assigned back to the requirement
so
by using the natural topography
not putting the problem letting the air
into the side
to the tune of about 15 minutes is
you'll say that's that's the none of the
problem
is
what we can't do is apply
um
say your words no I'm trying to
understand all the budget uh
that's what makes the difference
is across that please
try tonight yesterday
and
remember yesterday you were asked by
those facts about Mr Robertson's um
images in his appendix and
every particular I think we described
them as Roman or something
various uh
[Music]
there's a pending said has a series of
images
[Music]
Mr Robinson's appendix
3.1 we're going to go past because
there's nothing to see because of where
it's fine yeah
similar to one of yours it's just
coming down the side of the conduit tip
towards the green belt looking well
similar to one of the audience I mean
it's essentially the same as as your
photo
for
um
yeah these are folks are long time is
created by model by computer model
and Mr Marshall will talk about that
later but do you have any
on the services
the actual fact that you suggest has
been around for them have you sent them
to somebody who does this sort of
modeling work every question
now
look to the important signs they
received the line of agreement and we
also see the effects on those points
that separate the basics
accordingly at least once along with
really nice
for me and it's like looking at the
mountain when you estimate you can't see
any agreement at all it's used to why
it's not just the same but this one is
you can't see that banking at all
so so and that's just if this happens
maybe if this isn't accurate then it
makes your position that that
demonstrates that there will be no
particular pattern absolutely
just uh as I see that now we we cannot
see and no one can argue you know
because it doesn't understand me like a
true representation when I talk to
parents to the to the longitudinal ruins
but
it is
[Music]
you can't tell
we're not trying there's nothing to see
here that really stands out I don't
believe this is
a Confluence of that
I've got your own
um
in terms of disability
when you all join with newer considering
to see one of the photographs
sustainable from
he's shown in terms of deaths that we're
all within
[Music]
um
very short very close location of such
faces themselves
which are outside
um
they're the same
the only obviously there is many of you
in the area
the visual area is very content
on these photos you know on the ground
in reality we've not put any of this
forward for a very good reason just
can't see
you can seat down to this area or to a
constantly
you are suggesting that is the expected
to do is to speak again she will be able
to see the good spirits
on the North facing slope of the Canyon
City
if that's what you suggestions
is that your proposition I'm not going
to make that statement but I'll let
there inspect ourselves
there isn't it
simple question the question is that
from further south
beyond the topic there is no visibility
that's right
now and I can't remember exactly where I
was when I couldn't understand
Green Mountain purposes
we know that the green belt purchases
that we're interested in AMC alone
checks for
assistance safeguarding consciousness
so
school is the thing to be avoided
the thing to do is to check it being
unrestricted
that's the right approach to consider
Elvis presidency
your truth I think your approach looking
forward to you we saved the costs
service are part of the residential
development they must equal
s what they actually are in physical the
busy audience to determine whether they
have an effect
sort of
my understanding is that the other
developments
and that's the point is
one small world so so what does it rest
on because you say
uh being Improvement but it's because
it's associated with four
residential and hypnosis surely my
question again it depends on what is
actually done and what it looks like
as well when you look at the bookshelves
I've provided with other uh sorts in the
area who producer
initial built on
and that's what it was basically time
difference environment
right which feels over the hill to
Brazil that responsibility
that was considered there a separation
between the build form and the organisms
so it's just deal with some of those
important let's be repentance to the
over exam points
they're in urban areas
by the council potentially you I don't
know
um
they are examples and is it your case
then
um
if there have been approved or granted
to an awfully restored building and it
was inappropriately
that was
other developments
so you're not saying that it's appendix
2 shows something that's similar to the
immune system
substance
speaking we can't assume
because it's nothing they're not the
same drawings they're not the same
scheming they're not the same location
it's something that you point out is
looking because we also is reflective of
something different types
the other examples of public storage
looks like you've given other examples
is restricted
these basins will be there cleared for
the variety of development
they cannot be the result
they are a full start to development
they are an absolute valuable to and
check it unrestricted sport
certainly also when the
my design
although anxiety as it is there's a
chapters
that really examinated scientists coming
forward
do you accept the point do you see them
you're there for the lifetime of the
development
except that there can also be built okay
except the Philippines
except that there was always about where
they are
and the new the new site boundary has
been recording requires other uh spoke
about yesterday the designer accessories
and assures the clear intention of the
developers or something new about the
brain
there's a real sign
another necessary certain values to be
the parts of the screen partly so it's
been manageable relationship between the
ability we are this is clear there is
included
exactly that with the development the
builds environment
is removed what they consider that new
balance foreign
um
clearly it's one of the exceptions
you say it's not saying ss10
um
let's just have a look at SMS
page 55
[Music]
.
for performance and developments I'm
really into the part for the other forms
of development which may be appropriate
about providing it is important
with its purposes include anonymous
nbcme
the word include you've signed up some
clothes
so I've asked this question and they've
said we use it on a day-to-day basis and
it feels like stuff but the word
includes
let me just put this in very simple
example
these are many of them
includes is an opening list
patiently and obviously
we use it as I said
that would be a misuse
and therefore if it is to include those
things it is not to explain the numbers
yes
and this has been an entirely consistent
provided or uses the words include
schools
um
[Music]
and within the less waves
and what use is it that you say is
um causing a new problem because when
you describe this in the United States
you actually simply repeat
change to your language form to create
substitutionalism now that's the
engineering operation
the use of assumption today so is what
positive management
very occasional
maintenance
it's well it's it's changed the use of
everything
is
that the lines
here we never made the difference
on the effect on on the mid of that
material
changes that's what
that's what we want to look at that so
so the material change you use I think
they've made that clear so you
determined if it was and then the cost
of your interpretation of ss10 isn't
closed list he said it was automatically
it was inappropriate when it came to the
local Department
the latest 21. so in terms of the
paragraph 150 you maintain no
inappropriate nursing equivalence
um
[Music]
you don't go on to say anything to be
amount of degree abilities
important
[Music]
when you actually said it was if you
wouldn't know how to be oily
disabilities
this is important it's present back to
these applications
three five seven for whatever reasons
but there is absolutely nothing
foreign was
if the service can't be in agree about
the time information automatically wants
to be resumed okay
um on that one I think that's that's
something we don't have been as a final
commitment I think it's fundamental
enough that it is everything about it
and we should only have a as a as a
planning as an authority in giving
information on the sites that they've
fully looked at but I find enough
employment opportunity
something else Etc but then this was a
consequence
as a consequence
the original must run them forward in
terms of a local plan respect that maybe
included like I mentioned yesterday for
396 and this soldiers following you know
build a basis for a few things
you say when you're looking at the
benefits and I think this is your
essential challenge but we should only
be in fact
the difference between reasons
and he's saying in terms of 2028 there's
no reason to do other houses
um
application has been used
it was reduced for so many reasons
we've already named three Exodus that
you wanted to reinstate all of them
it's clear to us that rage
are concerned with all of them
there's another thing
Anthony names
this is the whole tactic we're not going
to see what it's going forward if we
carrying signs anything is
found
that's your position it's exactly what
you're trying to achieve no we should
still get elected in there obviously you
hear something down to me in person but
like we've got a plan in communication
usually knocked down to the old version
well it goes to how long we might have
to wait to see the advantages
foreign
[Music]
there's a current waiting list of nearly
two and a half pounds
there is a huge capacity
there isn't an important lesson uh
but that's the same everywhere
so we dismissed no no no but it's it's
something we accept and it's something
that works in the world I try to cover
some of these podcasts about an
acceptable inspectors so he was going to
start me a good time
but if you trust me on it and went
towards what we have and what our
objectively assess needs are as it was
asking about noon certainly knowing you
it's 80 Millions
when there is a massive meaning and we
agree there is
no I'm not going to read it I don't
think there's much of anything either
those are books and some things with
much of it in and there's a massive menu
but yeah two two and a half thousand
people on the way to the excuse as well
indeed
two and a half thousand real people
wanting Amazon
you know and exception
the reason there's another 20 times this
because we're not looking for me the 397
that was accepted that the sign will
deliver
um that's that's been accepted before so
we looked at pigeons which is the the
extra 67 ounces and then we applied our
policy at twenty percent
you know
yes
what I can say is I'll get to this
system is 172. it's 172.
and we're not meeting that this is not
just for the council that has to deliver
it our own our objectively assess the
need for a house is 283
we because we are cruel house building
and then we probably don't know
sorry
big street that it's like an amount of
stock between third side that we uh to
convert ourselves if you look at 20
percent of that especially when we are
172.
private landlords and this all managed
ways so it's not just down towards to
deliver on affordable housing
so the reason it was the carried look
away kind of standby is
20 and when you look at what we've
actually done as a council we work
towards it so if you look at the ones
we've actually built uh there's been 621
build and we won't expect anything
similar to this because it's not
um
if you're asking about reporting laws
621 built from the beginning of March
2004 to March 2021 and that is as it
happens 20.5 percent
and to the house that I've been built so
we're actually meeting our policy
requirement not meeting our not meeting
the agents at least you know but we need
internet policy requirement as much
worse as a council
and that's monitored uh annually by the
council we realize it's important but
we're not in full control of the
situation
and saw those extra 30 hours
[Music]
thank you
then
[Music]
and then when we come back we're going
to start hearing from the influence
and say if you want to make yourself
comfortable in the time
um
foreign
thank you
um you asked me a question about whether
interesting parties could make closings
um it's not something procedure new
inquiry uh when just support this way
choices it's normally for a rule six or
four
um
to do that and that's for the rights
that they have when in the inquiry
procedures
um I just wanted to get both sides
correctly because this is a slightly
unusual pacing that I realized later in
the quality of arms between the council
[Music]
um
Ghana uh your opinions fast it's going
to make your decision on this
I think it would be unusual
I think there was an opportunity to the
time to become a real estate party
I think it's importantly it's about the
statements that we run out yesterday
were with us before
happy
I live across
my little treatments
I think that those have consequences
I remember when I decided to treat them
I think it would be unusual and it is it
is
already
I think of course
um I recognized uh that has already been
asserted that it would be unusual
[Music]
either way
okay
um if I just explain as well
um
the reason why
distributed at the backgrounds these
sorts of words is that I mean quite a
list of certain rules about deadlines
and where we hear evidence about new
evidence being introduced because
required
you wanted to do
it
guys
[Music]
so so what I was interested in was it
because it clearly you acted as free is
it a summary of you know I was agreeable
wasn't an individual thing yeah
[Music]
um
thank you all right
um that's helpful
um I think if it was more
of a very brief thing that you wanted to
just like a very summary
um what's amazing of how you move about
um and whether it didn't institutionally
opens that's something I might be
mindful to consider but I think as an
individual and I've had your
expectations it's been very
um my decision would be not to be here
in whatever
um
let's move on then
[Music]
thank you if I can introduce Mr Morrison
to the inquiry
for his qualifications and experiences
[Music]
worked in the public sector as well into
the private sector and getting below I'm
sorry to see
lots of theories in terms of what
appeals
Authority development plan section of
the 178 inquiries here it was a
compulsory Productions is that all
correct and
um relevant to your experience and can
you just briefly set out your experience
of dealing with green metal collapses
and green metal pons we are certainly
um my main company and my role is the
involvement of the local bank
during the regulations
practitioners
can you please start
I'm just explaining and I don't mean
there's a granular generic area
that is an overall effect on the skin
um
this is important because I'm not sure
the actual rationale or why the sort of
places
so we heard already that that support
would be the same thing and my show
Independence
um
what I mean by that is the allocation
that falls over 144 reasons
that's why
it's my name
I'm on the drainage strategy the
reference for you in my group of
evidence is five to perform
two and what I'm trying to do is is to
take
a lot of drainage work done by the
experts
at the moment
allocation signs infiltration is being
shown to the Bible and therefore whilst
there is some per collection it
questions it Overland employees
in the allocation site and also probably
flashing it provides a prominent on this
informal funding on the salt area and
foreign
[Music]
experience is that water has no way
together and what it builds the airport
represent watches across that hasn't
made yet down onto the road and that's
where the possibility to explain
suitable and existencies of importantly
within the road so that's a pre-existing
problem and we accept
and it's my experience is the problem
because it's an unmade drive
so what would the drainage Consultants
have done
um and again I've been protecting the
specific references
um but they revise the strategy that
captures
[Music]
assessments associated with that of the
Rogers police screens or which is senior
seven young age
demonstrates that solution resistance
[Music]
the basic principle is we mimic new
existing drainage characterization and
and again I can give you the references
of that I've set all this out to my
buildings principally
what that allows us to do by putting the
Subspace and at the bottom of the hill
please to capture the water from the
southern weapons
capture the water from the allocation
site all them to be discharged
so the right side the picture besides
north side
the allocation sizes
what it says the valley science form
part of that natural organ
certainly
in between
foreign
[Music]
um I'm also advised and this again is in
my over 527 that it would perch the sort
of basin above that low point there is a
danger of Springs forming below it would
again solve the problem
and the last points around 13 was higher
um is I think it's important Sega and to
the witness to we would have to
construct an element of reinforcement of
that face within the allocation
[Music]
so
I'm not bringing forward an alternative
to what I'm saying to you that is the
rationale that is why
the subspaces and where they're doing
but if I can just follow along with the
dream strategies
yes
[Music]
sorry
Mom so the overall drainage strategy in
utilizing mimicking and working with
things is
the water comes down onto the new you
know it flows through slails or
roadbillies it then goes into oversized
pipes and the oversized paint not in the
middle of the elevation element holds
that water and actually the oversized
crimes are between half an intern and
winter lower than the results so the
other side is pipes fill on and hence
the discussion around the very important
retention
all the time
yes yes
so
[Music]
into the research
that really is that the character and
nature which I will come on to ultimate
compared to a simple
you know I I do set out and I've sat
down within my evidence invite to write
the policy approach
um or some places and I I don't propose
to go through that in detail but as a
practitioner we are clearly moving more
and more towards respectfulness it's a
policy imperative or anything else
there's various policies requirements
utilize sustainability
and that's this approach that we're
doing and to be fair and that's the
approach that all around symptoms
so there's no reason we use all our
allegations and any
um any Community Solutions
so that takes me to a point at home
where we
perhaps has not been put across so far
where you can see why we are coming
forward and what we were doing and what
the nature of these faces are paying
depressions
rather than Engineers that I'm
interested that we've been told and what
problems these are a different future
foreign
[Music]
an engineering operation it was an
operation supervised by an engineer
demonstrated that that's the case it's
not necessarily only designed by an
engineer it's a collaborative
appropriate landscape and everybody else
but really it has a function
and things are building then is so
expensive engine building operation
again
and the other lineage point is literally
real changing use
it falls within the same paragraph It's
subject to the same
text
s
it is it is
that there's a issue here in terms of
the answer to your question uh yes it is
uh index e
um and it is a material feature of
course
it is
yeah so this looks Basin as I say it
will not be substantially different than
that which access to the moment what I
mean by that is it is
two elements are not different in terms
we are not proposing properties
address that and if it perhaps
um
[Music]
questions
being essentially extend this decision
and the two paragraph references that
again Witnesses have been taken to
before over 16 of the secretary of the
states
um
put a decision
[Music]
learn system
should be
highlighted the proposed ones who are
would be in a change of use of land
then when those Services enabled
drainage infrastructure
engineering information the inspector in
the Secretary of today clearly had a
separation
I think we attend your losing this
instance for recreation and you don't
have writing in our place and the
engineering of operations of sustainable
learning things that paragraph
16 does not complete
but if we were just for a moment
soon because
um is it subject to the same the viruses
yes exactly
um
occasional exceptional and management
sort of Maintenance activities and I
know that that occasional or a sexual
management activities I'm advised by the
privilege engineer would be once it was
six months
that was well stored on the change of
news stories
but
I'm a closed list there's an experience
changing news reviews
these are examples of that's what it's
exactly
you know
is there any real difference
so let's turn to the preservation of
openness
um being the Proviso absolutely and
I'm just interested to know
freezing corporate process is there a
reason why
[Music]
assessment with an identity buys because
of the
um
softness of the slopes
it was an engineer a sustainable
advantage
that might be a different scenario but
it's not so with no danger and it's
simply mindful in order to be able to do
the currency directly and we don't need
to be really supportive in that because
we're already exceeding the company of
the space requirements during the summit
so and it was a it was a choice that we
would have made
[Music]
um
just in that Secretary of State decision
my opinions uh six perhaps the drawings
for about the organizations the elements
Associated
um and the sustainable Urban drainage in
that scenario sat directly within Park
um so to in the Greenback in the green
card
um there's three times and the last
drawing shows some drag and basins
somewhere else and therefore in this
decision and I'd be to the side to the
preparation Fields but I had no
involvements in this scenario they
clearly excited
[Music]
and actually
inside because it brings a little bit
mixing together so again it's north to
his own within interface with the green
about here his Justice site
and just while we're here
um
I think in terms of a plumbing condition
we've probably putting a condition that
said it will be depending what we resort
to do and if you have a look at the
ambition the final conditions to reamus
and exposure associated with
discouraging and that means that I
enclosure in the green vote for the
edges or shoulders
within the allocation site the draft
position indicates that that will be a
performance
foreign
[Music]
have we been
we would have no no problem with that
money it was it was a judgment I made in
the planning applications
[Music]
and you can have a look at its own
in terms of those stories
the figures
outrageous I think 35 yes
[Music]
one two three
with some of those
is less than
1.6
and basically just
keep that number in mind and I don't
know whether you've got this too long
we're going to those appendix
and just for the
for the Simplicity of the point the subs
area was identified in totality though
the green belts and non green Bells as
well 0.0 and just over 100 yes the total
load of space
6.72 containers taken the entire Sun's
area away from the entire business who
you've got
yes
and you compare that back to the open
space requirements for the number of
Growers that's in the stadium
just under 1.6
your thoughts in terms of the
sufficiency
that's
that's because of Mr walshaw sets out
that he only took a design labor
Solutions several of these areas like
reminding the ribs they might be
existing ecological areas so it's not a
formulated population with the minimum
it's pacemaking and I mean so
it exceeds the public purpose phase
it let's do anything more on that I was
going to ask you to explore
preserve openness first as a because it
was a concept and then set them as an
application to the scene
so approach
to
preserve numbers what was it what does
it mean
yes Mark so
um
it was established that we might be one
very clear that the engineering
operations all fairly and squarely
within paragraph
and program 160 has a single test it
says
um provided that they preserve it I mean
whatever that may be it's openness and
do not complicated
so that's that single test the testing
paragraph 147148
relate solely to immigration the two
separate things that are absolutely
separated and I think that on the face
of it it's very clear that 1471.8 bill
with inappropriate development 149 is
buildings and doesn't have the test the
additional test of openness and purposes
yeah
and that's
that that deals directly from a
practitioner needs in sorts of cases
I need to understand them but I think
paragraph 17 is very very clear and I
think it's already been taken but we all
knows the conclusion is I think it is
quite clear that buildings for
Agricultural and Forestry and public
development
yeah and that is not significantly about
are not to really wounded as either
harmful private in the openness
I think that is very very helpful but
actually it's a confirmation of the
practicality of what I've just in terms
to do and I think what that allows us to
do is to do that single approach single
assessment that comes back to openness
and purposes and I think once we once we
do that and again and listen to the
custom examination this morning it's it
also cost us 0.1 once we do that and we
undertake that as assessment of that
Towing station
[Music]
again that to me is logical because when
you look at
[Music]
well perhaps more relevance to this
place
um
I'll come back to engineer them but
mineral like structure we've already
we've heard about you know Verona which
is receiving 618 but there are always
noise Works around the edge of these
activities there are spoilers there are
activities associated with their
equipment but they still are identified
as following one
engine use of London
golf courses are probably because they
have changes in levels that's the nature
of them
houses all of these things change the
physical nature the changes in the
opposite word change the physical nature
of the women that cemeteries have grades
and all of these things I just think
logically as a planet that makes sense
um and when we go into the engineering
operations our specifics
and again we've already been taking
something else because
as well as the vaccines
so as a matter of principle it seems to
me entirely logical that means
um exceptions are a simple reason and in
line with some
reaffirming the principle that there
will be change and if that change would
still fit
foreign
[Music]
and that's the point it goes during the
development
which is not one lay the glass or or
soil results
so there's a I think what I'm saying
there's a correction
having maintains you within preservation
of openness yes perhaps the Judgment in
any place as to what about thresholders
about it yes and that's that's what the
year was Monica such a judgment
[Music]
um
the legislators the people that wrote
the Nvidia at that same time in the
program the law doesn't get involved
judgments are made by the decision
members
oh so not only that
to this case I think we've got which is
importance you know first is the
presentation of everything else doesn't
depending on no change
the second mostly determined whether
something is
a substantial but applying that to this
case
yes
um
548 in my group uh the workings
now so
resource demonstrated that the
assessment of openness we need to look
at and this is the theoretologist we
need to look at what elements and
minimum melt is impacted and that's not
just the scientific
whatever area and it is effective and I
have identified that and qualities
seven and because of the Topography of
the site and because of the Southern
um the humanity then I I have a drawing
in my opinion seven if it's easy for you
to to get into where not only have I
decided
to development
team and you will see
and age where you fall down to
photographs kind of all visual adverbs
you will draw an angel
which is a broad annotation
um
behind
um so what I've done is to is to walk
all the views and unidentified a very
very localized area
that has that has the potential to be
addicted to the challenge
and it is localized
um so the next final of the marvelous
the Hampshire and real estate
so it's the majority of the applications
so I've started from that point of view
and what's the area I've then looked at
[Music]
um
certainly sense than the question being
in the following story too are there any
news not of the allocations
but of the area of that site that's in
the being about the application sites
and the
photo that I've just taken to in a
pendant 7. you can see on the bottom
lines outside one two three they are the
location
is and The annotation shows where the
extensive allocations that it is
and within the development allocation
itself once it is brought forward
[Music]
visual relationship
and there's the relief from these to the
west and when you look at that time in
taking into account
um
yeah I I think if you don't mind to say
that can I come to that I'm doing a
visual assessment developing this so so
there are what I'm trying to do is to
perhaps walk to the site with the
landscape with the design in order to be
able to get better communities
so I I've established
um
the potential area potential receptors
and really
um there are paths willing to do it
either end around
the actual area in between those
footpaths is not supposedly
um
so it's facial terms and what I've done
is to look at what is the actual change
what's the nature of the change so first
of all
um the parameters plan confirms
[Music]
and we put forward a condition
indicating that there will be no
scriptures because there are structures
tables except they can be outside of the
community
so the changes
[Music]
and I I don't subscribe to there's a lot
of issues that water is a spatial change
so what I've then looked at spatially
I'll come to visually
um is the natural or unnatural element
of the form
um so can I take you down to
along sections and the cross sections in
her evidence experience
[Music]
themselves but
um in terms of the
packages that we've identified the first
drawing shows the uh between sustainable
Germans you can see the headlines
blinding either side of it before bats
on either end and it helps those
continuing existing temperatures
in this sort of area so it's um and you
may be able to pick up in the key that
the grassland was a while for our Meadow
usual grasslands there is a Pedro hold
on since some of the boundary and
they're asked for added trees ability
but in terms of identifying the form of
character what we're simply to do
anything
what we then did in terms of the
cross-section is very smart which is the
third
um
and I think what these cross-sections
doing
um
and show how this sits naturally in that
pre-existing
um dry garlic so you can see that in
terms of the the change and through all
those cuts
there is gems
um but that change is very very minimal
in cross-section because it utilizes the
existing uh working through it
I'm just to sort of give you a context
where you can see on the left hand side
at the words that sounded rebounds
perhaps
and then the red line is the age that
distance between extensive greenbelts
and red line is about 20 meters between
20 to 30 meters so what we're actually
talking about here
is
half of the substance
in the 20 to 30 weeks of strip
this is cross-sections
and you can see how the indignity rate
the changes in levels tie back in
to a southern Mountain
and you can see the video
nice
um
[Music]
there were sort of two
looks about sections across the points
that we divide between one Subspace yes
and what you were just making about time
here that we actually look at the
sections themselves
and it's just in the context of this
point that was being brought by Council
on Fox television appreciated
significance of both natural levels like
ground grains of the events in between
the original basis and I explored with
things that we've got to think about as
in the context of the surrounding around
North and South
can you just
let me have your thoughts in
relationship because yes certainly so
um both uh DD and Gene Joe land raising
in that location and that one reason in
that location is of about two meters
Foster was doing was
and we played team one grazing and
around the reduction
upon
women
and from the Green Belt boundary moving
towards the site family room
[Music]
yes
not so exercise on the long sections to
give you the context and you can see the
scale bar and the total lengths between
the two put paths so when you can see
the long section working through
um the total length is about 300 meters
this is this is the wrong section of the
source area
and itself everyone but I'll say it
anyway
um the change is tying to existing
levels of either end
such that we are we we start at one pack
level when we finish
and everything turns back in and not
overall but overall thought across that
whole section is about 12 meters so it's
been put to you before this is a black
postural rhinestone
this site has a series of emulations a
series of progressions a series of
activities within it in order for it to
happen
[Music]
which is why I'd explain the rewards of
angles all the way down
um
so what's within that context what we've
identity right um in the individual and
handling out this morning are those
maximum changes of both
[Music]
um
and again you know mutually this is an
indignity
but what they do is demonstrate this
overall fall down the hill from east to
west
and they allow the viewers the
Australian individuals
they allow us to still see from the
podcasts at this open landscape falling
down the hill with a series of
um impressions
in New Orleans against to the violin and
you can see that we've also got
hedgerows in there that's for other
trees
anyway
the Subspace is guidance and the records
that this is cv7 wides
which is the uh the drainage everyone
inspired by how it's far and that's
paragraph
fourteen what do you basically telling
us is that such guidance television the
side soaps or sorts should be a maximum
of one in three
we're just going to say that now is when
I don't think we have talks about
engineering operations or the Secretary
of State in law is thinking about
engineering operations and soils that's
what it tells us is
and you can see I hope in this annotated
pattern that we are talking about one
five one and four
this is lower that this is not support
against
so if the maximum is acceptable in that
definition we are smoother than that and
and I found that quite hopeful so I'm
just thinking about that but what is the
what was the framework for all of us and
I think my new spatial is that these are
a series of naturalized impression and
it currently has a series that
neutralize situation so you'll see them
as it is changed
those women
describing the ministry of Wellness in
terms of them the language is as soon as
I was important
then there is a maintenance strip which
is to the right of that and then there
is the angle of the photos for the
second so this is a specifically series
of
um
level changes that are that are not
similar
certainly not really
war or about 14
um
it's very hard to be able to to equate
that but from my point of view
um sorry man let me let me do it the
other way
we've had discussion around
um the Waters of base and what is upon
in my read book called
document the very last
photographer
where the last one
is a photograph of a sustainable
Learning Journey Basin as exists that
that's good I don't want anything
looking forward I worked through that
you can see on the edge that is a 103
therapy
and you can see in my view that I know
exactly whatsoever inspection and yeah
we are better than that and that's we've
had this sort of discussion and we all
comes right now it's about the photo
montages and whether they're verified
that's that's a canvas
[Music]
if we turn to
we are at all eight pounds
what Dr of those agency doors
um is and this will also take you
through the detail of
um Power and why what I'm going to say
is is functioning correct but it takes
you through
um the very final viewpoints so if I
step back
I want to decide with Mr wilshaw our
drainage engineer and our landscape
engineer uh we're honestly
and if we look at these movies first of
all view number one
you will be able to see the only changes
on the left hand side track which is
flashes what we are proposing as part of
the gaming strategy is to grow up that
you know
landscape that such that that flash no
longer happens but for the purposes of
the assessment of openness
um of the source problems
Viewpoint two is from what is or should
we
um
put it rights of way and then when you
come on site you will see whether public
lives in way does not exist and an
alternative has been created and we
might need to buy that in our building
come back to about the system but we
look at the ability for that to be
reopened if that's what what ultimately
happens
but certainly to retain the existing
Trump
visible
3.5 this is at the end of the code of
the whole road again say you've got a
certain people institution and again you
cannot see
um if you are very sharp eye as Mr Sega
was on the proposed on the very very
soon just to show you that that is a
proposed and a verified view that you
are
foreign
water
is is very helpful
so blue point size and you can see the
location of it you can see The
annotation of where the green belt Edge
is
[Music]
um
which includes in the store becomes a
positive or didn't say about the
suitability of these drawings if they
are right but they are important and
they do represent the students
in my appendix and they do take me out
but will break the levels and they do
take advantage of this concerns about
Daniels and that's the view so visually
in terms of where we've been missed and
we do not accept that there is only harm
in terms
and I can walk you through all of these
if that helps to view.60 from the
um allocation signs flipping out but
then the tie-in back into the southern
Mountain you're going to see it on the
uh on the bottom drawing and again
perhaps the next one for me to take you
to a relevances
the
the opposite one of the important uh
so
if you've already been taken to the
weakness of the existing New World value
which is uh
and hosting the rail events and what you
can see in our Viewpoint AIDS is the
extent of the sustainable that have been
drainage you can see the new age and the
new trees yes
[Music]
so those those
so again that's you working through
there I do not accept at all that there
is any visual harm Associates turned out
again is it fully verified you know
looking back towards these uh
foreign
[Music]
as a practitioner
I'm very comfortable with that which we
have delivered at the Wakefield City my
reversal Finance for that is
I think that's to demonstrates very very
clearly that this is appropriate
development
just to finish that point on the degree
of activity and
I think I'm coming anymore questions
irrespective and originally that's on
those opposed we get done we see new
knowledge let's go back to those other
exceptions
[Music]
foreign
um our purpose to be a neighboring town
instead of Common Ground the means that
were a third-party resident did tell you
whether we are within a Sacrament began
and which is
your reference page 57 of the local plan
they were recording by the show
certainly that we are not
so it's identified specific exactly the
gaps
um
yesterday
there
[Music]
isn't it
and that again
policy tests but it's a similar sort of
an issue around coalescence
um
also and women's public times so
restricted store that was seeing
Safeguard from the recycling
what does it mean
it gently is to stop it means to prevent
um and the important is it relates to
that because it will be restricted and
sprawl is a different word and it
becomes a story if you want
um and I know and I'm supposed to us
because what Greg saw by an earlier
comments around sustainable Urban dreams
being there and do not exist
so what does what are we doing we're
creating a
sustainable living drainage basin a
series of places that will be attending
perpet maturity in the life of the
development
is one of the strongest elements that
you can provide we always will give you
two guidance use to tell us about it
whether it be principal boundaries
um
that is a strong band but it's not just
a physical it's a management
so remind you that started absolutely
yours prevents
School
and there was a sort of um suggestion of
what this was all about was revising
changing
yes yes
there is no
question whatsoever on this video about
that
really changed either as an aspiration
assist you because again it's been
looked after the value of the existing
band in my view assessment
are you around being seen before 112
specifically says that page one two two
it says that southern vanity is correct
um what the local planning sector
says
please tell me if you want to pull
things up or not for what what's what
she says
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
control
yes Mama then your your reference um is
5.67
um
so I spent a lot of the time there going
through indicative administrative
schemes in order to demonstrate that
um sustainability races are capable
what happens
I've mentioned already the conditions
and control the disposition of uses the
requirements is one Advanced Studies
we were here on the conditions section
because Wells Council and we disagree
over the science board and we have a
similar view about controlling and
providing the brain work for the
membership of the sustainability coming
forward I say it needs an initial
commission for the ground Society
conditions but the ability to
controlling the future
um sustainable evidence
about ourselves absolutely
it's
[Music]
um so
6567 the types of
um restrictions that put them into place
no problem whatsoever
um
um so any more on greenmail before you
briefly I think just touched on the end
of
um previous reasons and any more you
mentioned the local time inspection you
mentioned that that paragraph about
um Greenwell bearings on the evolution
of the local time
and I think
um
that was covered in cross-examination
but the actual
facts and the detail of it I set down to
buy everyone so if you want to see that
chronology that this decided to
pronounced across the food you can see
it in many other words it is plainly
obviously but there was even a savings
of Common Ground between the council and
uh
then
mentions
[Music]
applications
so I can't accept at all because
um
[Music]
and he tells me that was a proportionate
assessment of the local ones that it was
storage as opacity with micro drainage
to obtain a volume that wasn't in that
modeling or design and in fact within
four months
and brought forward an eia and screening
request and that Bia screening request
didn't have the sustainability
But ultimately foreign
[Music]
but I'm doing experience
the other reasons unless there's
something more on that and I think we've
probably launching
um
yes
um happy to do that happy uh happy to
take your guidance really working
through without definitely one of the
reasons for refusalem
evolution of the reasons refusal
um
so advances have concerns about them
able to characterize all those concerns
wouldn't relate back to The annotation
assigned in elevating the site and it
was accepted
[Music]
and
um
[Music]
foreign
you understand
those
um
um it is
almost decision
is also
um
there's nothing to do with it that
doesn't provide anything yeah
and I think also remember it seems not
to development management
control which is an approximity
by accumulation of approximations
foreign
if it helps from a partner's perspective
it is exactly that it is another
location site and as we all know our
patients are through a very rigorous
process that I've set down
sustainability appraisal and that
sustainability of Praise all the forms
of
arts and things
um the sustainability appraisal uh
important part of that equation to look
at is approximity to Services Public
transports and everything else
[Music]
together and identify this site again
the stage in the inspector assess that
supports about the banks of identity
well I hope as we've seen when we're
recording assessments those assessments
documentary
and called the
isdana it's a standard
um document just Falls
testing humidity services
so that also forms part of green shoes
learning the issues associated with
education and health they will consider
that that strategic role through the
local vulnerability by
[Music]
um
processity and there is nothing no
showstop was identified through the
local fund process with regard to
educational Health in Illinois
in detail if that's necessary
um
with regard to health similar exercise
obviously the local plan and
subsequently as part of this appeal
process we've engaged with the right
people in those people who are on the
ground around
that last there is capacity in real
world network of
um
there is a specific issue that
Associates
contributions Awards
the network and they will be able to
sort of where that goes through a
process to do that and we've taken
review in the section 106 we practice
conditions
foreign foreign
right
I think there's only two other topics
one of them is millions of arms
and bearing in mind you what was in your
case on the very sustainable very
special services
[Music]
thank you
yes thank you so uh if I deal with the
matches that you put them um the only
local fund policy that is to be tested
environment
with my wheel on that and that wasn't
previously
UMC associated with uh
consumption and we also asked
yes
[Music]
well the Heritage assessment
I I cover it in in several areas in my
group but the
world knows um the clearest way that we
agreed to do it with the kind of saws
thank you
is
taking advantages
um yes
um so the uh recyclable part of the
setting of um
and in the old parliaments it was
negligible in there or didn't have an
impact that I worked with this place or
says that that means
substantial so at least
I set that out to the 64.
um
[Music]
so
the benefits I'd like to run through
that approach
um
recognize
[Music]
so
Advanced people say from them
so it's just one thought well that's
really
um resetting this potentially affected
um
is apparent and that's definitely
in the story
before
the September 181
um
will has been
Horrors every time
um
so in terms of the
are you saying
for the mentality that's suppose yeah
and then there's a supplements
yeah
so okay
just the same
foreign
and I'm thinking should we want to
responding
um
March 22 yeah sorry my apologize the
first one was September 2018 is 1942
um
in 2017 March 2017
which is the concerning the most music
one or two Thursdays
the reasons
the first chronologically in July 18th
and 1912.
it's not listed and I wonder why the
September in July
saved and I would mean
continue
foreign
[Music]
universities
thanks
again
so on my um
consumption but if you disagree on those
conversions
accelerations and whatever teaches
Heritage advance
foreign
[Music]
anything
there too
New York City
I just want to make sure
my Society yes
[Music]
certainly important to yeah
thank you
at 742
foreign
thank you whether there is a living
because as far south is
a college
so
building
since there's a lot of functions
between
guidance suggests
academic advantages
is
[Music]
so in cb12
.
um
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um
it's not what we're talking about
yeah
it works through
um
significance
I guess my point is
in the absence of anything between the
class otherwise
what an extensive list of listed
buildings
how do I start finding these
accessibility awareness and descriptions
completely
it gets quite an important point
yes of course modern
um
I dare say we can provide
covers our biggest and descriptions and
local questions from all those symptoms
and as I speak now I do not know whether
any background that erases which
informed courses in the community report
it may be that it is
but I cannot say
yeah
it's
enhance his position
or whether they consider of course we're
seeing a sensing of all of these
artistic buildings
that they
've written down
remember they considers
it does
probably feels like contributes to the
significance of each
instabilities
and what led them to them
find a place away from my acceptance
but if I'd like to know if that is done
it's a mistake
like 25 or listing programs
yes of course
um
healing
things
organ insurance
[Music]
yeah and then I was reading from 744
yeah
[Music]
foreign
um
I work this time I can offices at the
moment as to how we got there it may be
very simultaneous
we understand
um
thank you
so that's Westport Farmhouse agency
yeah
completely that's what we're talking
about
and that's that is what it is
um
and I think it's a very similar race
of the references
because you're thinking out loud
by the way to work out what the signal
thinks
I thought um
it was one thing coming into classes
that I've got I think you don't realize
there's a section
um
[Music]
sorry was that what we originally was
doing yeah
it was the July 18th page six speed and
set them to you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
to 90.
so
um in terms of so I
Bachelor I don't think we need to do a
shiny balance because we have a
presumption of protein
so the importance
services
[Music]
thank you
no no so so
um
that we are proposing the existing book
bus to go through the Minnesota area
of what we have done as part of that and
overall rebuilding packages
those in order to enhance
approach and Instagram
[Music]
so it's not a guidance
it's 6.9 million percentage
foreign
Plus
benefits
I can go through as much detail if you
want on this one and early the starting
points is we deliver
against one of the most strategic
allocations
so I hear what the council say about
thank you very much
but actually this is a meaningful moment
but I was in astrology
and it's an absolutely
so I looked at Market housing
and I that's what I do a substantial way
to that
is
mine so
um
the section we're looking at now for
positives is essentially a seven point
eight
through to
um
we deliver on the local 597.8
we deliver
um
[Music]
activity of that
conditions
[Music]
when we corresponding benefits
associated with expenditure in the local
economy again with my experience and
substantial weight to those and I would
just find out that something can build
Parts have mentioned this before on the
list of killer Marsh regeneration
framework killer mask is a set of
Industry Council by focusing upon
regeneration so the ability to improve
the housing style widen the house we
start and the actual expanding children
but this isn't a situation whereby where
that explains symptoms
um
thank you
um next one is affordable housing
um this is my paragraph seven eleven it
was rehearsed in cross-examination but I
put the figures in here that
um Mr Sega put to the witness
um
the delivery of affordable housing sugar
tracks substantial ways
um
it's fundamental it's important set out
to there with the affordability ratio
has increased and got worse and written
totality of the
um needs his significant and in order to
be able to deliver the totality of the
affordable housing I listened with
interest
um for Council Apostle said and I do
accept that the planning system does not
deliver all of the affordable housing
but it has to deliver as much as it can
apparently complacent and say we've met
the requirements this is the local fund
requirements we are happy together
the annual delivery of affordable
housing again
but on the same page these 78 uploadable
houses
and he does not need to be overall
requirements
so I describes a substantial way to that
we talked about biodiversity again
um my view is that whilst the
environment Act is is
not a requirement we asked the policy
requirement to support them again and
the biggest interest in you are
significantly over about that and
therefore as well
there's so much in space
foreign
[Music]
is
um
[Music]
61 better than to see CD 7.1.0
but really feeling is about practice
and I'm the last question
thank you
have you considered that outcomes very
social services
[Music]
um
going to give us one of the masses this
afternoon
we might not have seen this is
[Music]
lunch again because
I'm going to make me one and you know so
I have to go out and plan on this
morning but you can imagine if you're
preparing for an inquiry the last thing
I'm thinking about is going to Starbucks
um
thank you very much does anyone have any
objection to me foreign
[Music]
um right so we need lunch break anyway
and then we've got two hours of course
examination
um
that's probably going to take this thing
again today because I don't know about
anyone else but it's what I went to
yesterday
they are around the training and think
about this
what do you think science
I was just saying I think
um
trying to be sensible about those things
um we've probably had a lot of time for
the cost examination started
yeah
well I was going to um
yeah okay
but it was
it seems a little bit more difficult
yeah maybe find out almost just
sensibility
and I have got that bad things
tested
you know I don't really see a position
on the Master's side you know I think I
mentioned that emotion at least we're
not intentionally precisely I mean my
point is I can take things right
I need some
um and results
[Music]
foreign
thank you
it's 12 15
um so what we're doing
something like Mrs Johnson who
unfortunately
hundreds like this
[Music]
um
you know
making requests and and you understand
thank you
okay
um foreign
foreign
[Music]
the same name
I think that's right
okay
um
support
religious positions obviously not wants
to introduce everything
but that's also been explained I must
have been honestly so I've been to for
electronics
completely represents a section of the
humans is very important so I'd like to
support it after the council
it was to be really
issues to machine pleasing but it would
have to be performed really well as well
just in case
not great position that we raise all
right yes
it will be an amazing scheduled through
um Thursday afternoon
I suppose
we'll share with us
yeah that's another very good
signification is that we want to have it
written down and shared both sides
um
[Music]
tomorrow
um
he'll send it to me and make sure
so I would say sort of by closer play
today
oh yeah no I mean it's usually quite
late
although it will be here until five BBC
I think it would have been
yes
it was just to avoid any confusion over
this I don't influence you with the same
lists or any list of buildings
associated with the West points
um
and
I don't think there's been over over
many years confusion over a property
which is on the academic side known as
Western farm
and the holistic building which is
Westport farm and heads they are not the
same thing
yeah so if you if you have a listing for
what sport Farm herbs
you will see this is to the north west
of Westfield Road
and the buildings between London and
Westfield Road including the evolution
listed agreements the outlines
and that is the other side of West
thought on the other side of the green
the triangle area and the green space
versus all farm is is off the land
towards the side in other words of the
bottom right
and what we didn't know is we used to go
and see what sports are we focus is a
list of building Electronics the science
and then completely wrong
oh thanks apparently it's it's been 20
years plus 20 years
get in the wrong place and all sorts of
things
yeah
the other housekeeping points because
I've checked and I can I can make
um the other Witnesses available early
in the morning
so
[Music]
um and whilst each of them has done
essentially for me and his producer
speaking notes was to cover the problems
it's time
and we can let you have Max the each of
those it's a short note in each case but
it just sort of it's what they will be
saying but it saves the pain
and so I don't know where we always work
but at some point we've seen myself
I think they're all available tomorrow
yeah absolutely agree
um but with that in mind I really would
like to finish it by today's
foreign
[Music]
um I'm really slightly
um the summary in my distribution of
this document because I have natural
residence
but I'm instructed but it's still price
and we'll distribute them
um and in the last five minutes
literally
um
all of the buildings that are listed in
the uh report
and again I can distribute those on but
now all those
just
that would be probably ever heard of
that matter but I am being instructive
that's um only West for the farm it was
regarded as the audience that I lose
the applications
I have just gone into the you know that
West School have gone house the listing
building and it's associated with this
what is that like consolation officers
advice
okay it's so
you can distribute those three points
we're down to it now but just naturally
we have copies for everybody else and
you're emailing it over on one side yeah
[Music]
thank you
it's already been important
um
the conditions
you know
books
um
yeah
something or is the cross-sections
matter
they don't
because the uh listen
the same translation of these
students
oh yes
so we'll just we'll forget your solar
system
[Music]
five document at six then is the
conservation of this is comments
there's some learning issues
but the Niners progress
Urban Design
[Music]
support themselves my ways
yes
Mr Robertson I I'd like to start
with the treatment of the allocation
site at the development and inquiry
stage
um
this morning but I left them to the
total here in Australian management and
you demonstrated that it's not in the
series that the inspector
was aware of this outline application
um that's right
um and I don't think we need to go back
to look at that document because as I
said there's no dispute about that
um but could you now have a look please
at the inspection of report
which is called document 4.1.2
um I'm going to take you to paragraph
100 naity which is where the inspector
deals with the
allocation site
one
he describes it as comprising small
field Parcels when closed by
intermittent pre-line hedge Warriors
um you see that no doubt
and then
um
and where she was dealing with the what
will become the new Greenbelt Foundry
who says this the reinforcement of these
Southern Health re boundary
and you know called Green Space plan
would assist investigate individual room
actual development
and will provide a 30 Marketplace
between the built-up area
and the countryside Beyond
and will create a strong Independence
now
we're asking is referring in the first
line of that quote face
whether we enforcement or the southern
heterot boundary
yeah we must be referring through the
then existing contract messenger yes
the importance is that that is the the
hetero which we've seen in photography
will come back to those
which runs along point out today
that's right yes
he refers to that women's course Metro
boundary
space Japan
as providing the clear demarculation
between the built-up analysts and the
countryside Beyond
and creating a strong defensible
Greenbelt bandwidth
now
the
outline applications
in the foreign
very exciting
roughly 50 50 over that Greenback
it is
not just
use based money
would you prefer what they're not
sympathic referring to them
reinforcement or what would have agreed
is an old disintegrity boundary
and a careful green space app
now
that that I suggest is that those words
should be read together that's what they
have in mind if she was contemplating
with the new Green Belt boundaries
would be somewhere other than the
existing Network
people
it's quite very difficult for me to know
and you to know what she was thinking
I'm going to be if you we are talking
about the sustainable and drainage area
at the moment it's the rebound boundary
is more extensive than just a
sustainability
she's talking about the totality of the
new band the totality of the new Landing
from crisis head to those it comprises
gas has been shown at the rise of
sporadic trees and what she had in mind
of because it's later on it'll take me
to it was the outline protection so for
her to talk about the southern Hydro
boundary and Care programs based funding
she really has a mind to all of that
government she didn't just say someone
had her own phone
who makes Western extremity to existing
extremacy Brooks is only how long is the
southern boundary
I don't have that information I've given
the information across the Civics
can we agree this it was such 300 meters
comprises these substantial majority of
the length of the southern boundary
happy that I find you can take meetings
and look at that
I mean you could look for example
at the indicative care
yes
but that one shows pretty sustainable
Urban drainage
so there is probably a third of the site
that's not
um
that side and then there is another
proportion beyond the sustainable Urban
drainage so I would guess
foreign
thank you and there is nothing in the
inspectors report
who suggest that she was contemplating
moving to increase
from that existing lives
sorry and it's
become anywhere other than that along
the line where it is
the local fund establishes
of what she was causing of was the
technical work associated with the
online applications
so having regard to that she's saying
that magically it's both
of the green stars
you accept resumes in a sense it's
obvious that along this 300 degrees is
also of the certified
which he was referring in that paragraph
is completely lost I didn't find the
place at the end in the US officers and
and so if there is to be additional
separate relation and a defensible
boundary it has to be somewhere out
associate
because I'm not suggesting that the
green belt boundaries
what I am suggesting is that we've
basically acceleration
is going to move
the feature that provides within
separate
is going to do no I I I understand that
you're suggesting that but I do not
accept that I I go back the green belt
assessment I've indicated that Southern
Hotel it's weak we've already looked at
photographs
the inspector have that evidence around
that through the allocation the
inspector wanted to see this transition
on this demarcation and we inspection
identified here that that will take the
foreign
delivered to both of them and get a
problem and to finish the point and do
Muslims apps that the subs is an
organized elements the service is part
and
um
being provided by a a road Bank
we've got a lot of money to do what we
see is content about things
[Music]
visual impact and visual separation the
final line
in that paragraph by the problem which
all separation will be maintained the
nearby assessment of student health so
this isn't this piece of land is not
provided that Vision separation this is
for part of the evolution of the new
Green Mountain
between Black Rise sound more
in the green belt boundary is that right
yeah
um
the existing Southern Hydro boundaries
that is retained will be entitled and
the capital greenspace fine of which the
sustainable early range
or exact careful degrees
so as we agreed the Greenwell family
does not change but the new hedge is not
can you win that because it is a
component of like careful Green Space
producing provides
business advice
and again so the final sentence of last
paragraph indicates that unequate visual
separation will be maintained that's a
separate point which I've already talked
about the localized views I've already
talked about it's not to supplement that
and it talks about coalescence and one
coalescence it will not there will be no
coalescence visual separation will be
known as providing evidence to identity
by where viewpoints can be taken obvious
and have identified the importance of
the sum of that what the inspector here
is talking about is mitigating visual
impact of development and literally a
demarcation
separate sentence
but make sure I understand this we say
it provides a democrates
but not visual separate
the inspector is thinking again sorry
we reinforcement to the Southern Hotel
and Airport Louisiana
provide a clear demarcation between the
military
information
we're going to move on to approach to
the green belt I'm sure you don't need
to know soon
uh or two there's certain other forms of
development which are also not in public
prison Group Health providing and
preserve itself
now
I want to declare that there's no
dispute between us
38th
in the post-development
Falls Within
the 100
effective results and and reserves
openness
and does not conflict with the words
then the assessment person stops there
so I'm not going to talk to you
about that
is paragraph 106 a closely
yes
and if we look at policy access today
um the
potentially not in an appropriate
development
um
in that policy includes and is clearly
I don't know I presume it was Modern
growing that it's clearly not working on
up to date with the new parallel
between the new paragraph on the MSS
then it's a word
somebody
wanted
so you you say that despite its
um
because
the local Authority are Italian maybe
it's a good idea in Dubai development
policies that they choose to manage the
development within their
foreign examination
the time that this one was adopted it
clearly passed those tests otherwise it
would have been found on sound in seven
years includes the word that happened in
the policies
so on that basis policy SS plan could
have potentially
um
well in principles
videos
yes
now you referred this morning when did
you came into this class which wasn't
good
um the
indicative
proposal was that a pretty southern area
or have been
but available for Public Access
I understand
yes and you say that was changed
my recommendation to discourage yes
what were your reasons for making that
recommendation
so I had regard to the advice
um with regard to assessments of
openness and I've had regard to the
degree of activity because I've learned
inspector
I'm not a degree of activities part of
that overall assessments
I also had regards to the necessity or
any space
requirements within massage and I also
explained into relationship into the
evaluation and the outside
ruins and I felt it was not necessary to
be open space unless it wasn't necessary
to be available in space then in order
to
work at the openness and the beginning
of activity I built upon balance it was
more appropriate
visual viewer about the effect of over
the years
for Public Access
did that that was that based securely on
the level of activity or were there
and so I've I've gone through the
assessment of the station and the
regional and come to the third calendar
and the third element
of activity to the coach within that
so the direct answer to your question
is
if you regards Public Access
as effective either in the social planet
don't think I went through that thought
process
um certainly with regards to spatial
spatial
with regard to visual there would be no
components that I'm aware of of a
physical aspect how you know
for adult space paraphernalia Labs
um
so therefore no I didn't know how the
society was so annoying
the difference between
Brazilians
[Music]
already indicated approach that I've
taken to openness with regards his
facial as you want it and universities
operation
and I've already had set down this
morning under the right approve of the
exercise that I'm going through it must
be a direct question about activity
foreign
[Music]
pretty good
thank you
um
if you look at the set
if we look at the one in five third
season uh the green slow
which is done from the lefties
we say don't worry running beneath that
slow very dotted line it's quite
expensive
yes
and what does that bottom line represent
ative
and we see a similar line in the
configuration for the left and that we
want to go down
presumably what I shall call the Verizon
area above
the new ground level
um that represents presumably the
highest organ beyond the cross section
this line here
above the line above the new ground
level
there's an area of grieving you can see
trees growing
I see the very famous
or does that represent
ative
the southern land but I don't know how
the usual
right well I'll stick with what we do
know which is the existing ground level
and the proposed ground levels
um I'm not Shannon you your gradients
and therefore don't we need to go into
it or some indeed to help further
um you accept obviously because we
forget everything's about it this
morning
and that in relation to the county
production setting problem there
um the height from the uh talk to the
bottom of the slope around them
and attenuation
and then there is
within the end of februx invasion
um
from Dr Wilson at a distance of one
which is the central determination basis
the reverse attenuation basis on the
left it's length
from the edge of the basis what is the
history vertically
well the grammar level
um Dash and the build up from to the to
the
um
western edge of the first one looks to
be about a two meter raise
so therefore the depth would be around
one and a half one meter because in the
area again if I'm looking at the right
area these are both the existing ground
level so when you're stood on the path
to the East and you're looking across at
that occurs
um
elements you see arrays of about
five weeks
foreign
[Music]
sinks into the ground but actually above
ground level it's about again one and a
half meters
the advantage above the ground level so
as he thinks it's now that's the dash so
the biggest you've got something else if
I'm talking about the right one it's a
four meters
but really it's two meters down and two
meters up or not quite and that and
therefore when you read this you read it
along with the 20 meters away you
perhaps has also noticed that we've got
a head grow on top of it we should
continue to have drill working through
and therefore with you which is where
we're coming to the visual impact of
openness
we've had to look at the receptors and
the viewpoints you will have to look at
the distance of that you know about your
technology where we will exactly that
we've certainly two meters down and two
meters up to achieve through the uniform
meter
different
I mean this this is changing the
existing landscape into an obviously
artificial engineering landscape
you know I think again I've already
explained and set out
um there will be change
we've accepted that but that change is
not an engineered on State and though
that's change is a very naturalized one
state and it's very Focus around
depressions in the land which I've
already explained already exists within
the site
and actually the new points that we've
identified with my appendix age
reinforce that
appendix demonstrates in practice what a
two meter raise looks like and it's
imperceptible
but in terms in your
um
what was the purpose of preparing this
packet
so the
um we can use all these framed on the
basis of lack of information
we my position and it is very clear that
there was sufficient information policy
can make it to take the discipline and
I'm cited alternative real cases as
demonstrated that have also made clear
that offices didn't ask for any
information
and on the basis that we are trying to
resolve concerns between ourselves being
set in the Common Ground we have
disciplines we
read them through case management
conference and if further information
was available that we could provide and
may assist foreign
all right could you have a look at those
at the cross-certainty
that's
right
again we see that and I'll say PJ is an
example
and again we have the
Cash Line
varying the existing ground level then
we do and that is
[Music]
so if we look at Ginger
um what do you say approximately it's
really difficult
ground level and in the program
where
there is anything
it's the same one on the heart that
Julian says
we see that's on the scale bar on the
left
we see a similar distance where the
evidence is between existing ground
level and the ground level after the
material is taken away
again I suggest what we see there
is a cross-section
of the creation of an obviously article
foreign
[Music]
this results in gen but it does not
result in your heart it results in a
naturalized series of depressions and
that is my difference and that is a
judgment that's been supported in many
many
if we move down through that
10x3 there were two years
yes
what are they intend to demonstrate
so go back to the package of information
in the submission on the 3rd of February
this was the information that we had at
the time in order to on the table rather
than indicated and therefore they were
to take forward with these long sections
and cross-sections that we've just gone
through
um in a photo real basis and and again I
can go through that it would assist but
they were identified with the changes in
levels coming from that long section and
cross-section and they gave that overall
impression of this big Mountain View
naturalized landscape
again perhaps a question asking the
obvious that in both of those news what
we see is something that
a receptor which is the only if they
happen to be
passing the advice
it is right which is why I'm
supplemented them with my appendix
if we imagine a hypothetical reception
of the Moon looking at the the new one
um the
continuation Invasion that's more or
less independent of that
we can see
a darker green
almost joke
the
um
the nature I believe that the Run State
components
um so if you go back to the first one in
October or group
um this out this element is for those
neutral grassland and Wildfire Meadows
is it is associated with
um
my understanding of that stuff was it
was simply a graphic presentation to
replicate that I don't believe that it
actually was willing to show that it was
a differentiation
and it was the one right now
[Music]
in color
are you able to assist on on whether
that have had a name could have
the edge of the the size of the base
if you equate it to the 1972 before I
think you'll see
um
delineation of the photos and say I'm
not sure why the color is a different
color you can go to attendance aged you
will see the verified photo montages and
there was about 27 montages
before we assessed
Solutions
and we've received on for example view
contains
it seems to be simply the nature of the
cluster
and what we're talking about here is
well that's good
because you are looking at what
obviously proposed
yes
you can see there
the viewpoints out
um dark of the green but perhaps appears
to be slightly higher
than the life
you see that
they are in
basically physically right
the ground surface is too high
what
[Music]
is the changing color and let those out
why are some of their blood groups
it indicates that the president
so
if your hypothesis is right then the
size outside of the dark green they're
awesome so I'm not sure how that that
works I've already indicating the wrong
sections and cross-sections and this
creates change that that change will be
glass slide
working across the Elvis
and assessing survivors
I can't answer the difference between
the Congress but I can look at that
photograph paint and propose immediate
but that is a naturalized feature
thank you
right I am now going to move to Europe
and itself
foreign
[Music]
area
against cycling
how amazed background
and they have to stay away against a
gray background
um
[Music]
across the whole of the orientation
I have no idea
when you say movies
[Music]
people entitled encouraged together in
between Springs
are you able to say
whether any bars probably after the
posters society that is within the green
belt
is visible from Springfield
I am able to say from my perspective
that I've unwind and we're also are the
experts so the points one two and three
from the fund before I walked those with
them
um
but
fast
EST route
we
to set them up again
the traditional the hatch that runs
along the important grounded
[Music]
um that I remember is one of the the
head restrictions and alongside the
existence
and then running away from that towards
the central advisors which is is the new
health correct
between an exact support
um
really the houses
we see that definitely the creation of
the name of Einstein
you know we see that the edge of the
sustainable Urban damage basis and that
edge is actually within the housing
allocation the environment with the
sustainable Learning grade which
struggles in the application so you
don't actually see on this one green
belt Elementary
elements of it within the allocation
that they're respectful of that we do
not see an engineering
naturalized
would you say image 4 does not throw any
part of the application site
yes because it's down in the gym
so between the heads you take them into
the edge of the houses that element is
within the allocation because the
Greenbelt boundary goes right through
the middle of that so if you turn the
page to view qualify them and see what
I'm saying and you're seeing the winner
you look to the left on the side on the
2.5
um within the allocation we're not
seeing the area within the Greenville
you say that because it was built by the
New Hampshire 3.4 because of the
topography on that
what Topography is what I've been
explaining about the ability to gain
views from the southern land and when
that Southern Man is probably between
the base over here
very experiment um Finance proposed
again being
the rising problem being
with a lower right of that part of the
ground again is
I I still disagree that is very clearly
part of the overall natural Iceland
State and I was going back again to my
um
which is something very similar nature
to that um
[Music]
yes
what do we see in the correspondence
we see the sustainable Urban Trading
Places tying in with the Contours of the
Southern Mountain you see the new Edge
in the foreground middle ground and we
see that the way that the sustainable
Urban drainage assimilates the museum
that's a matter of
how the receptive reads it doesn't work
so I suggest again what we see those
landscape
but I I appreciate you suggest that and
I this is me and we've talked about and
go back over if you want me to the
context and the approach
what we are what we are seeking to uh
ascertainly is whether this is
appropriate development or not and
whether it is hard to the visual aspects
of elements
um one we didn't look at this morning we
won't take until this morning and we won
seven
um in the as he is Viewpoint assembly
um what is the
guitar region and the non-emergency
that's part of their exists in foliage
as you highlighted and that's within the
allocation site
conducts and we received even 16 is
proposed to be removed
the thing about 0.7 is that if that
really excited
can you assist
it seems to me
slow behind
where that footage is now
the rising stroke behind me
significantly been taller than the
proposed matter
advantages at the moment am I right
about that you know you know the
review if I'm again understanding the
equirectly in the existence is the
existing sort of around the only change
to the Southern Man being left hand side
of it since the replacement of the new
updates
and the recreational terms
that's what you see in the foreign
in terms of the Horizon
there's no change to the to the Southern
Man Horizon whatsoever went outside the
red line
you know one we've already looked at the
inside
and if it was nine
again and I know what you're asking
fairness
[Music]
that was my problem
foreign
very clear in my own mind when you look
at this this is a very very important of
what a clear representation of what will
happen which is a very naturalized we
can see this is a new Chrome
um so this is the new set of time what
will the sectors are using right the way
along the subs and they see the trees at
the end which is 8.2 and they look right
the way along that it's a 300 meter
length that I talked about
and they can see openness and
disagreement they can sing all of that
aspect that allows me to control
including the road about rescuing and
green space and the Natural Ice Cream
space
and no doubt we would say the same world
system
[Music]
now I I will before I move on I will I
will report this to you so I can't
believe
um I suggest that this proposal as a
whole
that causes harm to the openness
um which as was described by cancer of
his world was
considerable
um but I suggest that there's proposal
court has harm to the openness or the
green bell
um
some ways
which did not generate about
I'm going to move on then Greenbelt the
early sea
um we know
the two purposes
Technical
and encroachments into account
um can we agree
um to the south of the queen belt
boundary we're back
So within the applications yes
obviously then called The Proposal
um
it requires a development engineering
Works within the countryside
because you disagree with me about
everything
I say it's a program because I disagree
with you but also because I've
identified that as a point of principal
engineering operations are appropriate
so whether it's the application of this
site or any other
engineering operations
[Music]
and that's why I remember this as to the
extent of organizations
but as coders view demonstrates that was
of judgment which believes
online use and I've set out all the
context for the interviews
until the main review that's up to them
but I'm here as the witness when I do
not believe that this provides any form
of
um Urban School a sustainable and
Training System
will only arise in the context
in this context I mean you can have
sustainable early vainage and simply in
order to address progress
[Music]
within the allocation
this is part of it
and it is an essential part of it
without training which is
the residential development needs
drainage I've already explained that all
components of the damage including the
other side of the house this is a
requirement of the German strategy that
we've built up
that your
opinion that this development checks
depends on the point
you're all trying to manage that this is
not Urban Development
yes it depends not just on my journey
but it's a it's a clear view
is the clear view of New York
sustainable learning related
it's
because
it creates that chain
that it is
an appropriate development
the viewers take them
away
foreign company before
the original definition
that's that's the whole basis where they
think we have set out the elements that
we should look at and then we get
identified with those exceptions in
Greenville design area
so what purpose a is seeking to be is to
do what it says stop or the restricted
scroll so the question is is there a way
of restricting the development this is
absolutely restricted
for us
but without encroaching into it
I have to identified that over at one
particularly identifies
forms of development that are
appropriate against
so therefore anything you have to
identifies that these are forms of
developments
causing the demolition of the garments
in the running apps that are
uncomfortable for appropriate
developments
that's why he said that's why those
whoa and
um
what I'm suggesting to you is that it
really
it's not asleep
is proposal
Urban Development
which damage you which causes harm to
the openness
and the surgery on croatians
[Music]
and also also doing
I think a lot of them changing the
government support which is the powerful
if we inspector communities that this is
inappropriate development
we do not suggest really that there are
any very special circumstances with
Courtney nevertheless the Justified
no that's not my case
is
but where we are now to the skiing
um as implemented in the middle ears
you see there is no change in use at all
unfortunately
the existing Unity that is
um
occasionally points
and great
yes this policies
what would excuse to do after an
implementation upon
that's an entirely artificial there's an
instrument it's you supposed to
experience
it's all drowning and housing estate and
surroundings
it's it's use is that which is important
and it's important Society
there is no difference at the moment
it's a naturalized drainage Solutions
[Music]
through this process
I've already indicated once involved the
public data sets
just
in Europe
and presumably you regard the animation
aspects of the skin that's um
[Music]
Advantage experts please explain that to
me
right and then I'm going to be finished
with him
a great temperature through some of the
um can I
first of all
um go back to this question with numbers
of houses because it was pointed out a
smaller
again at the development stage there was
an indicative scheme with the books in
the sun's been within the unemployment
side
and accommodated those into the United
States
projects there wasn't a regulation 90s
um
is it in fact your professional opinion
the realization side
if developed with Subs inside the water
comedy
airport
slightly less than
uh I haven't done that exercise
I've Witnesses requested um
the regulation magazine master plan was
done at a higher level we
issue associated with where the drainage
was I've already covered so I can't give
you about some service too where there's
no reporting whether or it won't
accommodate and my proposition is that
each application has been developments
and this is the application
um
you're able to say that whether having
these Subs
cribe
it wouldn't necessarily
called any of the dogs
on that I think what I've I've tried to
do at least to identify why uh it's
appropriate but the sustainable learning
whether it is and I've identified some
of the
concerns they're trying to approach this
now artificial activity when I haven't
done this because
um
if you've identified them on some other
bandage actually the provisional housing
and you said this models there's nothing
to do with regular housing
about that
but of course the benefit of the
division of housing or the rise to the
development of the other places like in
any event or particularly irrespective
of where the
continuation
if that was in front of the inspected
but it's not what's importantly
inspectors this scene with this this
kind of goes back to my proposition that
we should consider in this application
will have vaccinated
of our job and this is an application
that brings those benefits an
allocations
but if this
is relevant wants to be regarded as an
appropriate and I appreciate you so it
is
so if I was in a territory where I was
making what a very special circuits
um why does your group address benefits
at all why do you feel that the program
is going back but as I put in paragraph
754 that I you know that this is
supplies I say should however we expect
and not to read then I set out for them
because that's that's the reason I do it
and it was clear on my group in that
process that's all I thought
I don't quarrel with that still to the
inspector disagree with you
[Music]
about
I
I granted by reminding me on the hard
arms which are neutral and benefits
provisional affordable housing would
arise
and answer the question again if it's
the same proposition there is a a
pressing affordable need which I've
identified with paragraph 711 that's
affordable mean or nothing satisfying
solely by the final system but the
problem system should not undergrades
its responsibility so from inspector's
desk right now is the ability through
this deliver 79 affordable housing units
yes
that they too would grow not really
developers
so it would be very rather than three
times
but we agree where we must agree
it's certainly um my my view this is the
applications
and the benefits growing from this
application there is no other
alternatives
foreign
and
imagine all the time difference just
imagine
communities
that the existing page
was
reinforce
we've got the search spacings
were Beyond this on that because it's
that way
through
and what was what is the head zero was
just
watching this scenario because we need
actually replacing disappeared and then
we Imagining the snow and everything so
slowly
I I didn't agree
um I think the the nature of this
specific set of services
but that's this specifically sentences
foreign
I think they they change would be
marginal time
you're asking questions about
one of the collaborations
we have a look at the key
there's two columnist second column
specifically their own
simulation basic water level
um
photographs some of those are monetary
people
families of us
the
um
find some water levels I think the
question I would be
of course was around like a little bit
of Victory inside the glass
[Music]
thank you
yeah you were asked questions about the
um
not to use it you know it was probably
doing things
it wasn't winded for a good question
how senseful do you think it would be
sort of minimize things of contention in
the world
it's another sensible
space of my assessment on the degree of
activity
foreign
[Music]
was
wondering excited about we specifically
finally
[Music]
I did
um
[Music]
what it tells us that how would you
understand that if anything is
[Music]
pilgrimage
another important is just coming forward
no I yeah well I believe that I was
bullet points on principles
[Music]
um
so clearly they were evolving their
thoughts through the process which you
probably would expect in making
representations to a local one and as
they evolved their thoughts then they
ended up with the planning application
they were the agents applications
[Music]
and then the point was I see that extend
a little bit sooner than
so this part of the Urban Development
when it was from the explored it was
that it serves a purpose for the
development of the houses
and are related purpose
um how how do you weigh those points in
trying to understand what's so smart
here versus what they actually are
proposed to be you know I won I listened
to that point yesterday and necessary
in the village
assassins is the one that tells us how
to deal with it
this was a proposal
um it's just imagine a situation
whatever this weather is whatsoever when
there was a really full agreement
because it was causing a problem
and the solution was the solution that
was proposed for this scheme of course
is just that
would he say it was Urban Development
now I'm trying to
explain it and that's I think not far
away from this uh this building down in
the development site behind us there are
um sustainable learning damage problems
within the countryside
accommodate range elements
and the last three in relation to change
foreign
um
[Music]
I guess so just Loosely and then on your
side
says they've been raised
sure sure
thank you
foreign
good night
is because there's already a remarkable
application which is a direct response
to the highlights that we've already
written about in videos
okay
so what should I was everything we could
do this afternoon before which I was
learning
quality is
ID
[Music]
um
you'll also see a large number of
science stories and similar issues that
was dealt with or just an example list
of them
and I think possibly also I would just
mentioned section 6 of these names so
indigenous in that the identifies a
number of sites but at least dealt with
them or not whether they're building
things that were online
that haven't been found
and how they were dealt with and through
the planning process with information
being granted and developing going ahead
and it just gives you know it's just
like the context of how these things are
normally dealt with
other than that Republicans have just um
yeah
which is in response to the Series
yesterday going to destroyed it
other parties mentioned mining that I
think Mr Edwards into those students
just talk us through
Portland that says we've got obviously
three pages
foreign
um and finally uh also there's one final
on post remediation issues
and finally
speaking has mentioned the issues
associated with contamination
so if I start with Michael Williams
um the point was made that decided to
being at work extensively from 1933 to
1984 and during that time really
intentional extremely important as
possible
so
I would say it's really you know that's
that's not really true in the fact that
there is quite a lot of information and
the investigations
foreign
so we therefore do have confidence and
risks of recorded working uh signs
maybe where the the former Western
tolerance
um to the western side and
it is from that colony where
the economies of extracted over that
opinion
beside there was a adrift uh what we
call it an Arabic which is a a British
line is where the planner house was
situated to extract gas
that the workings do extend on the side
of the commonweiling records on that
our words are accurate records and they
show the sharpest working there is about
110 meters and the co-workers also
conclude there is no further risk of
ground
at the surface Association
that's quite a key to think
the paragraph references
so those those recorded workings
are told using a lot of normal mining
techniques and there was a reference to
the amount of poll that was released and
that is why
we but there is confidence and certainty
with those working the shell locks about
the circles in the future
I want to discuss whether those
important workings are are just in my
statements yet
Nicole Authority also highlighted
potential workers in their colleague 29
Minority Report because I'm taking for
the scientists
and this issue was further the sexed
investing saved followed by extensive
exclusive investigation Works to provide
confidence in the present and a
distribution
important
and through that invested in order to
now have confidence have uncertainty on
availability
of assigned
foreign
to whether there is a risk of a
substance occurring in the future the
filling the Rarity will mitigate matters
there's also a reference to a very
simple interesting
um
so yeah the second Point receiving line
shots uh we've got there were five mile
charts now to be present or are
identified there are potential for
others to be uh just settled across the
site and there was also reference to
explain to you within those bills
viability yeah so that was just
something you've said yeah okay so
that's what we're going to be discussing
our statement there are actually six
recorded linemakers on the side
comprising one at it so that's an
inclined feature that's the requirements
I spoke American and there five shots
they have it on board which has been
identified until we were opposed of
those on-site from the two words one
mine shaft is not about to be identified
uh despite our significant happens
um
I said this is not a concern service
further investigating where it's moving
parallel and the coal Authority agreed
that this can be conducted post-pilot
commission being relatively consistently
with an economic conditions
um I've also proposed mitigation in
relation to the line entries or my
statement and we've acknowledged that
robust measures shall we require
components in the building without it
and of course
a reduction of no real zones uh within
the planning allowed
zones
what those would need to be for the
moment than those sheriffs they extended
between about 10 and 20 of these yes
indirectly from the essentially the
sharpness
are or whatever their names are
reduced
the
and that is
in terms of being found the ones were
already found the location
and that's this
and that has already been what was it
225 Australians we have to look for it's
in a 15 minutes explainer area all the
way around and all that happens there's
a difference
uh
[Music]
but in our experience um
and Eric Stevens my experiences that
were typically
um
England
[Music]
is usually no not really not at all
though but I mean um certainly not
fairly sites that are situated on the
cold field and particularly near to
outcrop
um and I would say that you know when
you consider the conventions uh
around the Yorkshire and doctors
um
there are many sites obviously we've
been doing it all the time it's all you
know and therefore they do have issues
with cello cold thank you for all
recorded working but it's the site
people will develop and tie this area
that uh currency website we'll see the
large proportions
situated in a development behind this
area so this is this is not a
particularly you know individual side it
does have issues and they need to be
investigated in a robust way which they
have been today
and the next point that was made was
about the fault yeah and lying against
yeah so the concern was raised about the
the whole fracture understood the whole
time and work still fracturing the whole
line creating pathways
we have also addressed the issue of mind
yes and we've undertaken a comprehensive
gas monitoring on the side and uh yeah
foreign
uh poorly um
there was a report of the media Works
required to initially
on the road and
obviously we we obtained in the content
with nine non-residential minor reports
and that included between police
comments on Lion guard and in that
except the coal Authority with no record
of my destination require an action to
this side
so we're not aware of that incident over
the road all we can say is that this
site you're aware that the cold
Authority is not aware that I mean my
gas problems
and then we mentioned the contamination
yes I made a brief notes on post
remediation
aligning objects to realize this is the
this is the football field I think it
was discussing along with the site and
this is slightly different this site
it's largely been over control
historically and therefore site like six
two meter turnover two or three wrongs
without the businesses there will be
largely our oppositions on this site and
therefore the risk of emergence of
minority factors also in consonant
online and the placements of cleaning
proposing the area
the final movement officer consolidation
issues that there was a concern raise
that um
each of their poly aromatic hydrocarbons
and they represented this to those
living in the apartment
statement
and you know we would we would highlight
the risk of certain statement as part of
our work are taking on a very concerned
basis of whilst the periods have been
identified at very low levels uh there
is a negative risk to the health of
those living adjacent to the side fear
the inhalation
addiction
[Music]
was um
um
this is um
[Music]
analytics which students will have
qualities
assessments it's just that you might
remember
today
and
his original report doesn't have a
section that sends out his
qualifications too so that would say
please
Exotics experience
guidance
[Music]
um as outlined in my notes here that no
specific National policies require an
important assessments for the support of
every paying applications the local
authority to determine whether one is
required or not
um as as outlined with my individual
airport as a statement uh
there was no public radio system being
assessment
um this was further the commented upon
the requirement of physical Force
um and obviously agreement on the ground
as well
but the locals have raised employees
agitates
exactly that's right yes
assessment now
um
providers and the results
Industries and operations
[Music]
foreign
and all of this
um
entirely
basic languages
objectives and also the relatively
traffic pose on local roads
um
what are the related points is that
we're monitoring the records
which is
the
political kind of situations
it is I think um when we saw the third
party yesterday was talking about
um wanted to finally changing evaluation
it's all about predictions
um
uh
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
yes
specific environmental factors submitted
into this site and recently so the
um the impacts from road openings also
mentioned the necessity to the
dispersion and modeling which is
recommended by this is
all the production of Wellness have been
to model to calculate emissions
to the sector and this included a number
of sites specific women boots
for records such as wind direction and
speed the temperature
in community and interpretation as well
John machines both in terms of natural
locations and widths and the roads so
let's take them to accountable Evolution
as well arising from
um we took it out at the average vehicle
speeds to sort of traffic flows
um
convictions and also the recessive
location in relation to the romance side
so that there are obviously focuses on
the roadside
um
okay thanks boy
um the next point was that in relation
to the uh selection of receptors
in the local Road Links are summarized
in the nearly statement the student
center location selected by the Southern
National highways
concentration everywhere but we've said
there's a little bit of considered to be
worst case when doing this to considered
proposing boxes the road inside the
potato are could have been exposed to
the higher service completion and also
in the traffic history and development
and the importance
of management
um
positions
in Wisconsin
exactly yes
Services
temporary factor which accounts for
traffic growth
device identical development
um but sending this software package
um
vehicle movements based on our published
International practice including
um policies and that that growth that
we've seen who sets out of exactly data
we can see with the Globes go up or not
somehow
they're mixed emissions associated with
the contaminated soils
yeah so um
finishes monitoring and control
remission is a good remediation Works
um
um so the next point is it's a similar
one in relation to industrations Field
of disruption
um so obviously a set of those
statements
[Music]
um
guidance
conservation images which are relatively
standard investigation units out
instructional science
that's right this is not also an
expenses
and supporting projects um
[Music]
foreign
responses
right so just to keep us on our clothes
sideways to the format Mr Blair Thank
you to go around them and then the
narrative text I think that's that's the
good way forward to look at the points
okay can I introduce you to the inquiry
first you can do that your
qualifications to experience at the
beginning of your main statements at 1.1
and can you just give us a quick
question
foreign
[Music]
civil engineer
fellow of the institution of symbology
Department of institution in which I'm
good institutions transportation
from 30 years
and well I'm sure you will have I don't
will chance to win the whole world
but if Mr Blue can just please identify
them because it's cheap Pages
if she shows them to sustainability
okay
so the first point was the answer is
because
we did some Benchmark and uh
excuse me
apologies for the criticians
so what we find was that the traffic
problems
in the future they're all in the world
in my previously tested so actually that
was demonstration in the previous
analysis between us
by what we did we encounters
that we find that they were lowering
about the original Assessments
in time
thank you and we looked at growth into
the future
we find that we're having September
assessments and we find that when we
move around the temporal assessment
about this law as well
apologize
the
um
[Music]
the analysis foreign
assessment
[Music]
we didn't actually simply with any of
the whole videos
[Music]
about 10 trips in the morning 14 years
we also did some new student services
they're very similar to what we've been
finding before but we were actually
around 42 miles
students
were used for Designing visibility
stories of licenses
we also just thought about the answers
again
but it shows that you know
eventually
we absolutely worse
and to considering this this
is less future growth for more
perspective there's less chance
these are a little bit slower yeah it's
almost different
and so the next point is run by Mr Evans
um
then
[Music]
um the refused accessors
um I think it might actually have
subsequently recruiting but um
what I can say is that it's um
which is appropriate
foreign
[Music]
Street
um
the highway code is 36 he introduced was
there something interesting put on
[Music]
so so
on the highest speeds in these 61 we've
actually got 81 and experiences
foreign
[Music]
and
of those accidents
or even invested
um I don't think so
foreign
[Music]
it was a point about
Independence
surveys
of methodologies
[Music]
is this
Services
accessible by a sustainable level and
residents can access employment
education and Facilities
it's not just about buses
there are facilities and services
legally accessible by walking side
building bus and leaving by a
sustainable car a lot of people it's a
recent development first the only reason
we have actually in regards
do them as required
um you know the Cycles needed
and it is accessible by sustainable
roads and the travel time on the Sunday
night
anyway
that our school bus services
[Music]
during the 397 owners
I'm dividing it through the sun which is
will be designed to accommodate plus
results
[Music]
both of those concerned to encourage the
Improvement services
um
the colleague was made with school buses
actually still related
well you know the next one dimensions
agreement as a travel advantages
school bus services are perfectly
developed
[Music]
um
all the information
the sustainability of religion has been
subscribers
but more than that representative
so it was just very much
yeah
it was a specific criticism
[Music]
student buses from the page right around
the stable 4.1 there's clearly
identified examples
and
I suppose to round off that points in
terms of new businesses to get to the
basis by bus
that we inspector
that was recorded appointments
sustainability
food
that's um
there are plus services and
development
[Music]
of public transportation or something it
is
you don't have to use a password system
will remain statement what the writing
with vaccines
insurance
from the references around
you can see where everything is you can
also see that um
this is relevant to the education
because the the distance in terms of all
the distance between
schools
well recruitment 14. well that's the
problem
14 Thursdays to some jazz
um the sustainability of personal report
says number seven who's a double
attracted eventually the group that I
walk through the ranch of the site
receiver
is
okay
um the first thing passing on Greenway
there's um I visited uh
versions on Twitter
personally the first time I've purchased
it on Friday in the morning when I
thought
the cars were originated
and experience of life with 10 seconds
it's all on a dash
canceling it
um
the reality is the deliveries
but the proposal why is advantage
meters
and with a part of the time taking up
approximately two degrees is adequately
within what's the pricing so I suppose
at my point is that
if we couldn't avoid me but I would
still look at my feelings
but we are working and the things
that because one of the suggestions
at the moment
services
[Music]
foreign
it was tomorrow
um
ecology
and
I would just mention what id now and
which is good race
thank you
well he mentioned as we were going along
um
[Music]
foreign
um
conditions in the highway Authority ones
I mean the fact that the highways damage
thank you so much
[Music]
times
foreign
[Music]
videos
um foreign
probably an experience in their
regulations and environment Generations
[Music]
absolutely
this is what I wanted a question to move
besides
[Music]
thank you
Fortune prisons if you want to use a bit
more time I would like to pay something
right
I'm certainly not the most people think
um I guess it happens I haven't done one
in one of
themes with conflicts or something like
civil research opportunities
during that meeting alphabetic raisins
um not available
[Music]
normally
only having yourself privately
I think we could do that the other
reason why it's important things
get to a Thursday yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I'm sure
foreign
is
[Music]
appropriate yeah
but
somebody else
just a very interesting
I think you would have mentioned that we
use okay
there was some points
I love sweetie just saying asking the
question and I believe
actually it's finishing up taxes
addition to representations yeah
[Music]
um
okay so tomorrow morning we'll come back
half time and we're finishing on our
other lessons
I mean
um
there's anybody sleeps on that tonight
[Music]
thank you
today
okay thanks everyone then and we will
listen